ici djibouti et bien les choses sont
parfaitement claires à la fin de ce
premier voyage de monsieur georges
pompidou dans un territoire français
d'outre-mer
le président de la république a
réaffirmé clairement que la france
resterait à djibouti puisque ses
habitants par le référendum de 1967 en
avait manifesté le désir et l'accueil de
la population
ces trois jours a confirmé en effet
qu'elle souhaitait le maintien du statu
quo la raison l'intérêt est pourquoi par
le choeur commandes ce choix la raison
djibouti convoité par ses deux puissants
voisins la somalie et l'ethiopie et sans
la présence de la france une guerre
inévitable se déclencheraient dans cette
région de l'afrique
l'intérêt la france par les sommes
qu'elle consacre au développement du
territoire
on a fait un lieu de résidence tellement
envié des populations voisines qu'il
faut protéger djibouti contre les
immigrations excessive et les
perspectives de développement du
territoire sont réels
quand sort en particulier construite la
deuxième route reliant djibouti à
l'ethiopie et quand sera développé le
tourisme se demande en effet pourquoi
les organisateurs de vacances si friands
d'exotisme ensoleillé n'ont pas encore
découvert djibouti la journée de mardi
avait commencé par une cérémonie au
monument aux morts et un défilé
militaire suivie d'une réception des
corps constitués
ce fut l'occasion pour monsieur georges
pompidou de rappeler les raisons de la
présence de la france
certains attendent peut-être de moi nous
aurait ainsi remet à cette occasion
l'appartenance du territoire à la
république
cela me paraît en vérité inutile cette
appartenance résulte la volonté de la
population volonté librement exprimée
avec la plus grande netteté dans les
référendum qui ont concerné directement
son destin en 1958 et de façon plus
significative en 1967
vous êtes français parce que vous voulez
lettres et le rester et personne ne
pourra aller
contre cette vérité d'évidence le rôle
du gouvernement de la république et de
faire respecter votre décision contre
toutes les tentations de sécession
quelle qu'elle soit et vous pouvez être
assurés qui le remplir a jusqu'au bout
après ce discours
ce furent sans doute les heures les plus
chaudes de ce séjour une visite de la
ville permis à la population de
manifester un enthousiasme parfois un
délire on n'avait jamais vu à djibouti
d'après les spécialistes 80 à 90% de la
population étaient rassemblés le long du
porteur il est vrai que le leader de
l'opposition ayant appris que monsieur
confide il recevrait avait levé les
consignes d'abstention voulant montrer
par là qu'il ne remettait pas en cause
la présence de la france mais que son
opposition se manifestait sur des
problèmes locaux si l'expression bonne
foule a un sens
monsieur pompidou à djibouti aura
compris ce que cela signifie aujourd'hui
mercredi avant de partir pour addis
abeba
monsieur pompidou a reçu en audience les
principales personnalités du territoire
en conclusion de ce voyage on peut dire
que des émeutes de 1965 à l'
enthousiasme de 1973
en passant par le référendum
territoriale de 1967
le redressement est spectaculaire dont
le territoire français des afars et des
issas il aura fallu ce voyage de
monsieur pompidou pour que tous les
spécialistes français et étrangers et
ils sont nombreux dans ce voyage en
prenne pleinement conscience ici
djibouti à vos paris